It's great to welcome to the program today,
Josh Douglas, who's a law professor at the
University of Kentucky.
Yeah.
And also author of the book vote for us how
to take back our elections and change the
future of voting.
Um, uh, great to talk to you first and foremost.
Thanks David.
Thanks for having me on.
So we could start this conversation a few
different ways.
I mean, I think for my audience, they're mostly
familiar with the different ways that we've
seen.
Um, uh, mostly the Republican Party attempt
to make it more difficult to vote.
This includes a reducing voting hours, reducing
polling locations, putting in place a so called
voter id laws, gerrymandering.
I mean we could go on and on and on, but I
think in the interest of sort of having, uh,
as optimistic a conversation as possible,
you identify a bunch of different ways in
the book that we can increase voter access
and turnout, which I think is a worthy goal.
And I think most people in the audience agree
what some of the lowest hanging fruit to start
with that might immediately give us some positive
results.
Well, probably automatic voter registration
is in some ways the lowest hanging fruit because
it's already been passed in over a dozen states.
And this is where the takes the responsibility
of registering everyone using the information
that already has through DMV offices or what
have you.
And essentially the voter registration list.
And the DMV lists talk to each other.
I say this is a little hanging fruit again
because we've seen success in both so called
bread and so called blue states that have
adopted this reform.
And when we talk about automatic registration,
there's a couple of different ways I've seen
it work.
One is when there is some other kind of interaction
with a sort of government system, whether
you are renewing your license or you are turning
18 or or sort of some other ways, what are
the different ways that this could actually
happen?
And is there some way that doesn't involve
any kind of interaction?
It's simply when you move in some place and
change your address, you're immediately registered
to vote.
Yeah.
So the requirement that you be given, the
opportunity to register to vote already exists
under federal law.
This is the motor voter law that says anytime
you interact with the governmental entity
and like the DMV office, they give you the
opportunity to register.
What automatic voter registration does is
takes that step of opting in out of the equation.
The state does it automatically.
You don't have to do anything.
So anytime you do update your address, say
with the DMV office, even if you don't also
take the additional step of registering or
or filling out the form, the state will do
it for you and then they'll send you a postcard
saying, well, you've now been registered.
If forever reason you want to opt out, now
you can.
And what this does, the results show is it
registered so many more people, Oregon, the
first state to do it registered over 100,000
new voters and many of these people turned
out to vote.
That probably otherwise wouldn't have had
the opportunity to.
Yeah.
That was going to be my next question, which
is the second order question is does someone
who is automatically registered rather than
choosing to do it, are they actually more
likely to go and vote?
And it sounds like some of the data says that
yes, they are.
Yeah.
In fact, a recent study looked at turnout
rates between the different states in the
2018 midterm election and showed that states
with either auto automatic voter registration
or are seen same day registration, you can
show up to the polls and vote at the same
time had the highest turnout levels and the
stage with registration deadline of 30 days
or three weeks before the election had the
lowest turnout levels.
So these reforms really work and again, they're
implemented in a positive fashion in a handful
of states already.
Now it is possible to play devil's advocate
that states that have these sort of automatic
registration methods are states that for other
reasons already have fostered sort of a more
engaged voting public and that it's not necessarily
because of the automatic registration, but
I think we don't need to necessarily get into
it at that level here.
It seems pretty clear that states that have
a certain philosophy on voting do have voter
turnout, maybe for a variety of reasons would
be fair to say.
Well, I'm pushed back on the question of,
or the notion that states that already have
engaged voters are doing this because you
looked at, you know, West Virginia, which
is the third state to adopt automatic voter
registration or Georgia, a state that has
had many voting woes and they have automatic
voter registration.
So this is, you know, you asked about the
low hanging fruit.
This is because it's already working and a
lot of places.
So you mentioned, or I mean, I guess we're
talking about this in the context of we have
50 states and different states handle this
issue and voting in general very differently.
Are there states right now that you've identified
that sort of in general would get like an
a on voter access and voter and Franchisement?
Yeah, it would be Colorado.
Colorado has, I think the best of voting mechanism
when it comes to election day itself.
Uh, it has, uh, essentially a combination
of universal vote by mail, also known as a
vote at home and vote centers.
So in universal vote by mail states, the state
automatically mails every one about about
two or three weeks before election day.
Uh, whether they've requested it or not.
So it's not like absentee balloting or you
have to ask for it.
It does.
It automatically, you may not even know.
And election is about to take place.
She can sit at home and fill it out and research
the issues and the candidates so that it leads
to a more informed, engaged electorate and
then drop it off at a secure Dropbox or mail
it in.
And you don't do that if you want to vote
on election day, if you need some sort of
assistance, the state has vote centers, uh,
which means that instead of having to go to
a home base to precinct their polling place
closest to your home address, you can go to
any votes center in the county and they're
all of a tragically connected.
So once you check into one, you can't check
into another and the ballot that gets printed
as about fear of home address.
And so this is the ultimate inconvenience
and voting.
This combination of automatically receiving
a ballot.
But then if you really want to go or your
polling place where a polling place, you can
go to any votes center in your account d as
well.
So on the other side, which states are the
worst as far as this goes?
Well, any of the states that have 30 day registration
deadline, uh, uh, Texas, uh, with the continued
rose, in addition to that, it's strict voter
ID requirements that really don't have any
benefit in reducing fraud and yet a disenfranchise
a handful of, uh, a good number of people,
certain constituencies, um, any of the states
that don't have this kind of convenience factor
in voting.
And we see it in the voter turnout numbers.
So, um, I, I'm originally from Argentina and
Argentina.
We have what's called mandatory voting, which
basically means unless you demonstrate that
you're living outside of the country like
I am, for example, or unless you have some
health reason or other reason for not participating,
and you've sort of presented that to the state,
you are expected to vote and can be fined
or otherwise punished.
If you don't, what's your sense generally
from a philosophical standpoint about mandatory
voting and then from a logistical standpoint,
is it actually something that would, um, be,
be desirable?
Uh, because choosing not to vote if you're
doing so freely, although I'm not in favor
of that as a strategy, it is something people
can do to show displeasure with the system.
It is still a conscious decision people can
make.
Yeah.
Argentina has that.
Australia has a mandatory voting with turnout
of over 90%.
Um, and you know, this leads to, it seems
like a pretty engaged, informed electorate.
Um, and so it philosophically, I think anything
we can do to encourage participation while
coupled with improved civics education is
a good idea.
Now, do I think this is likely or possible
in the United States?
No.
Uh, I think philosophically people are against
it.
Although I would note that in any mandatory
voting system, you would have to have a, an
option essentially for, I don't like any of
the bumps.
Um, and so the requirement is to show up,
not necessarily to choose one of the candidates,
but I do think that if we adopted all of the
reforms that I mentioned in the book, thanks
to these everyday Americans who are championing
them in their local communities, then we would
get to something a lot closer to um, universal
turnout.
And you know, I have it at the end of the
book.
I say, why not aspire to something like 90%
turnout?
That seems crazy don't in our current environment,
and given the numbers of 60% turnout in presidential
elections, you know, 2018 midterms had 50%
turnout and we were celebrating that high
voter engagement.
It was a record and I thought, you know, it,
half the electorate isn't showing up.
Why are we celebrating?
But I think thrive to something like 90% and
we make it part of the way, then we'll be
doing a lot better.
So I guess the next sort of layer of discussion
that seems relevant is you outline a lot of
these reforms and you talk about, as you call
them, democracy champions at local levels
are actually activating to try to get some
of some of these reforms enacted.
But there is to some degree, this kind of
vicious circle where the voting system we
have is determined in great part by the people
that are representing us, that our elected
officials, those are people who have benefited
from the system we have in so far as they've
gotten elected under it.
And so in great part they may not actually
be motivated to make the changes that you're
describing.
So what are the actual activist actions?
What, which pieces of this dude just activists
have control and power over and which parts
actually require first voting some different
people into office?
Well, it really depends on the state law and
the ability of voters to have doubt propositions,
whether his forum, local elections or statewide
elections.
You know, you look at a place like Michigan
that had horrible partisan gerrymandering
and the way it draws its lines and the state
just passed a state constitutional amendment
to implement an independent redistricting
commission to draw the lines.
And the next time we do this starting in 2021
so Michigan voters had the opportunity and
ability to pass about proposition requiring
that in other states.
That's not possible.
And then again, we talk about local laws.
Some states give their localities what's known
as home rule or essentially authority to have
a vocal specific laws for their local elections.
And you see a lot of movement in places like
Maryland and California.
Uh, in Tennessee we've seen some successes,
uh, for local reforms.
Uh, so it really is, is location specific.
But here's what I'd say is that let's make
the effort and implant the actions and the
places where it is legally possible because
that creates an evidence that creates a body
of evidence to show it to the other states.
Hey, this actually works to improve turnout,
to get it to, again, a much more engaged,
informed electorate.
And it's not a partisan power grab, it's simply
a democracy paragraph.
Can this discussion be separated from the
discussion about how politics is financed
in the United States or, or are these really
related issues that have to be dealt with
in tandem?
Well, I think the financing of politics is
its own separate issue to reform it, but of
course also informs the, you know, the ability
to make a lot of these other changes.
But I have a separate chapter on campaign
finance reform and specifically public financing
and what some places like Maine and Seattle
are doing to improve the access of ability
for people to run for office.
Um, so I think it's both a separate issue
as well as something that works in tandem
with all these other reforms.
And kind of in parallel with that, I'm curious
whether you see the way in which, at least
at the presidential level we have this, um,
uh, electoral college system.
I mean, is that something that you think plays
into the reforms you're talking about or,
or is that more of a separate issue?
Well, I think the electorial college plays
into the voter apathy concern that involves
so many of our elections.
And you know, one reason that people don't
vote as they feel like it's not going to make
a difference and why bother.
And then, you know, if you're a Republican
in California or a Democrat in Texas, you
think that, you know, the result is that essentially
a preordained and the electoral college.
Um, but that said, there's also a foreign
possible for the electoral college itself
that I talked about briefly towards the end
of the book.
And this is the national popular vote interstate
compact.
Or essentially states are agreeing that instead
of awarding their electoral college votes
to whoever wins their state, they'll award
it to the national popular vote winner.
And that's really gaining steam as well.
Yup.
That we've actually talked about that quite
a bit.
And of course, until there are enough states
who sum total of, of, um, electors totals
to 70, it doesn't get triggered but a number
of states, and I don't remember it, but it,
for some reason I think it's 12 or 13.
Is that right?
I think so far, maybe 12 plus DC now.
That's a very interesting initiative, which
we will, uh, we'll keep talking about.
Oh, we've been speaking with Josh Douglas,
who's a law professor at the University of,
yeah,
about his book.
Vote for us, how to take back our elections
and change the future of voting.
Uh, just really a pleasure having you on today.
Thank you so much.
This has been fun.